este vallado que se encuentra a mis
espaldas separa a este grupo de
manifestantes del edificio del congreso
de la nación argentina que está a unos
100 metros hacia adelante es un vallado
que no estaba se una semana aquí cuando
la cámara de diputados votó a favor de
darle el respaldo al acuerdo con el
fondo monetario internacional que
alcanzó el gobierno del presidente
alberto fernández para refinanciar una
deuda de 45 mil millones de dólares con
el organismo que había sido contraída
durante el gobierno del ex presidente
mauricio macri ese día los manifestantes
estaban sobre el edificio del congreso y
un pequeño grupo de estos manifestantes
lanzó bombas molotov y piedras contra el
edificio por eso este jueves mientras la
cámara de senadores discute para ver si
le da sanción definitiva al proyecto de
acuerdo con el fondo monetario
internacional estos manifestantes están
separados por este vallado mientras
expresan su rechazo al acuerdo que ellos
dicen traerá un fuerte ajuste del gasto
del estado algo que terminará impactando
especialmente sobre las poblaciones más
vulnerables del país aunque el gobierno
fernández asegura que ante la presión de
la deuda ante la presión de la deuda
contraída con el fondo monetario
internacional la única alternativa
viable era la de ese acuerdo que alcanzó